[Music]
bristling with weapons and confidence
these Taliban fighters want to show they
rule the road a sign of strength as
their leaders talk peace with the United
States like much of Afghanistan the
Taliban zweite flag hangs over this part
of Ghazni province these foot soldiers
say they support the idea of a peace
deal but they're against demands for a
ceasefire until all foreign forces leave
their country an unrealistic condition
no knowledge that the stupidest American
Maajid Bhavani stanky de mujeres rally
it's in criminologist stupid EC they
were noisy for a pramana by Randy
[Music]
Nikolai American food woozi universe
turbine la penita body bikini Shanda
Prabhupada champion debater and pop -
tank emoji de la marea his caliber
initiated this mid-level commander spoke
exclusively to Sky News he's not
directly involved in the on/off peace
talks but what he and his men think
matters they'll have to obey any
instructions to stop targeting the
Afghan security forces if they don't it
would undermine any future peace deal
President Donald Trump here with his
Afghan counterpart announced a
resumption of peace talks with the
Taliban on a trip to Afghanistan last
month the Taliban wants to make a deal
we'll see if they want to make a deal
it's got to be a real deal but we'll see
he wants a deal - having pledged to end
the war and bring thousands of troops
home but there are fears for
Afghanistan's fledgling democracy if the
exit happens too quickly
Marine Hawaiian injured his hand in a
Taliban attack in Kabul in September
because I'm making oh my god what is
your chakra
I got butter as enemy shoulder and blood
but I so Bob on the phone let me Jung is
staying with Johnny this senior Afghan
politician is worried her country could
again become a hub for global terrorism
she says the Taliban must agree to a
ceasefire and then to talks with their
fellow Afghans can you just spell out
what the risk would be if that happened
if the Islamic Republic of Afghanistan
if its people were not included in talks
with the Taliban probably Taliban can
come back with the same mentality and
ideology that they would rule in
Afghanistan and they will keep their
ties with all these international
terrorism the risk is not only to us but
the risk is to the region and I think to
the wider global community back in
Ghazni province these Taliban fighters
think they're on the winning side
inshaallah Matheny was ok the deeper the
loudness the lower third oliso hamas
away ok so how will Nikki preserve me
and she'll love us fighting talk the
road to peace in Afghanistan still long
and filled with danger Deborah Haynes
Sky News